if you have an idea you have the freedom
to do it or to pursue it
whether you achieve it or not that's
another question Furies rejoice from
Iran
I Drive a taxi cab
immigration
it's a contentious issue especially
illegal immigration and a lot of people
are talking about it whether it's
Arizona's controversial new law
requiring citizens to produce papers
proving their legal status or President
Obama's decision to send additional
National Guard troops to the us-mexico
border as the Battle of our
comprehensive reform heats up everyone
has an opinion what's less discussed is
the final stage of legal immigration the
naturalization process for new citizens
we wanted to find out more about
naturalized citizens like firuze who
they were why they came to the US and
what the citizenship process was like
prospective citizens attend citizenship
classes to prepare for their interview
which is a kind of final test to become
a citizen this point in the process is
the final stage some prospective
citizens wait to become eligible for
years but if they make it to this stage
they would go in for an interview where
there are 100 possible questions ranging
from who wrote the Federalist Papers to
who's the governor of your state they're
asked 10 and need to get six right after
candidates passed they normally attend a
naturalization ceremony like the one
reason TV attended in Fairfax County
these are some of the people we met my
name is a father guitry and I'm from
Sudan my name is Eduardo Daris I come
from El Salvador
my name is Wayne Nina
I'm originally from the Caribbean and
island called Nevis I was born Christian
and this is my religion I'm not going to
give it up because the government
doesn't want me to be Christian I'm a
computer system engineer and I'm also
own the company construction company I'm
a general contractor really privileged
to be an American citizen and Estonia a
great opportunity and my two children
were born here one is five years old and
one is one both ceremonies happen in
government buildings all over the
country approximately 750,000 people
were naturalized in the United States
last year to be able to break your day
up to go down and experience you know
one of the top five to ten moments of a
person's life to be able be part of that
it's very special the United States has
long recognized itself as a nation of
immigrants in the 1970s roughly 1.5
million people were naturalized and in
the 2000s 5.7 million people were
naturalized and immigrants continued to
come to the United States for the same
reasons the democratic political
infrastructure religious freedom
economic opportunities to raise their
families and one of the rights not a
goal not an aspiration a right the
pursuit of happiness my passion from
childhood is art so I got my
master's in fine arts I'm a painter
whatever the god-given talents you have
whatever the circumstances and skills
you will experience or possess have at
it
pursue your happiness unfettered by
others it's the freedom to pursue your
happiness that has also made us a
cultural leader in the world new ideas
new trends in everything whether it's in
politics or art or movies or whatever
starts here in the United States and
spreads across the world this is
basically because of the freedom that
exists in this country in every respect
and each person in their own field you
know are free to do whatever they like
every day
all over the u.s. new citizens are being
sworn in the American Dream is still as
powerful a draw for immigrants all over
the world as it's ever been
speak up
everyone heads right and nobody would
deny you a right I think many of us will
tend to take our citizenship for granted
will tend to take the freedoms of this
country for granted and we sometimes
forget to look around the world and see
what other people experience and
understand how special the American
experiences